the way that men get choosy is they fail
to escalate the commitment oh so they'll
just stay in it they'll just stay in it
without moving in with you without
proposing Etc if you're a guy and you've
got a girlfriend and you're happy and
you're having sex together why would you
suddenly just give that up for no reason
if you're happy in the relationship but
she's just not quite smart enough or
stable enough or promising enough to
marry then you'll just kind of drift
along indefinitely what might often
happen is after three months six months
two years if you're wondering why hasn't
he proposed to me why hasn't he taken
this to the next level well that's where
the men are getting choosy that's where
the men are now evaluating not just
physical attractiveness but the woman's
intelligence and character